aquí he dibujado la parábola clásica de
igual a x cuadrada y lo que quiero hacer
es pensar cómo puedo hacerle para
desplazar esta parábola así que pensemos
en unos cuantos ejemplos primero
pensemos en la gráfica de la curva esta
es igual a x cuadrada ahora pensemos
cómo se vería la gráfica de g - acá
igual a x cuadrada como se vería a eso
bien por aquí vemos cuando x es igual a
x cuadrada también es igual a 0 esta es
esta curva amarilla así que x cuadrada
es igual ayer hoy es igual a x cuadrada
pero para esta x cuadrada no es igual
ahí es más bien igual a menos acá
entonces cuando x es cero y lo elevamos
al cuadrado cero al cuadrado no nos da y
nos da que menos acá
así que esto va a ser cada vez es menor
que otra forma de pensarlo es que esto
es cero y si es cada vez es menor que
entonces ya debe estar en acá donde sea
que acá esté así que debe estar en acá
justo ahí
así que por lo menos para este punto
tuvo el efecto de desplazarse hacia
arriba la aie el valor de iu-ca unidades
y de hecho esto será cierto para
cualquiera de estos valores
entonces piensen x estando aquí para
esta curva amarilla si elevan al
cuadrado este valor de x obtenemos este
valor de g y claramente no está dibujado
a escala pero si lo eleva en este valor
de x lo lleva ahí pero ahora para esta
curva justo aquí x cuadrada no la corta
solo lo lleva al menos acá así que la k
debe ser o la que debe estar cada vez es
más arriba que esto así que esto es
menos k que debe estar cada vez es más
arriba que esto la aie debe estar aquí
entonces vemos que esta curva es
esencialmente la curva azul pero
desplazada cada unidad es hacia arriba
desplazada hacia arriba así que
haciéndola
- acá es igual a equis cuadrada pero
desplazada hacia arriba cada unidad es
cualquier valor que tengamos está
desplazado que a veces hacia arriba así
que esta distancia es una constante es
una constante que la distancia vertical
entre estas dos parábolas
ahora trataré de dibujar esto
limpiamente lo más limpio que pueda esta
distancia vertical es una constante acá
ahora pensemos en cómo desplazarla
horizontalmente pensemos qué pasaría si
yo dijera que que es igual a algo
diferente a x cuadrada x menos h x menos
h al cuadrado
pensemos en eso este es el valor que
obtenemos de cuando solo elevamos al
cuadrado el cero obtenemos igual a cero
pero como obtenemos igual a cero aquí
esta cantidad tendrá que ser cero
entonces x menos h tendrá que ser 0 o x
tendrá que ser igual a h así que digamos
que h está por aquí entonces x tiene que
ser igual a h una forma de pensar lo es
para cualquier valor que se esté
elevando al cuadrado para obtenerla y
ahora se necesitará un valor más grande
para elevar el mismo valor porque se le
van a restar h unidades a la x solo para
llegar al 0 x tiene que solo para elevar
al cuadrado 10 x tiene que ser igual a h
si aquí quisieran elevar 1 al cuadrado x
solo debería ser igual a 1 pero aquí
digamos para usar el mismo argumento que
este es el valor es x igual a 1 y esto
es 1 al cuadrado obviamente no está
dibujado a escala pero esto sería uno
también
pero ahora para elevar 1 al cuadrado no
sólo necesitamos x1x debe ser igual a h1
debe ser una unidad mayor que h debe ser
h más 1 para llegar a ese mismo punto
así que pueden ver el efecto de esto que
en vez de elevar x al cuadrado si yo
elevó x menos h al cuadrado desplazamos
la curva a la derecha así que la curva
en color morado la curva de color
magenta se verá algo así la desplazamos
a la derecha la desplazamos a la derecha
h unidades ahora veamos otro experimento
imaginemos imaginemos que pensemos en la
curva de igual a menos x cuadrada ahora
sea cual sea el valor de x cuadrada
tomaremos su negativo aquí no importaba
cuál x tomáramos la elevamos al cuadrado
y obteníamos un valor positivo
pero ahora tendremos siempre un valor
negativo una vez que lo multiplicamos
por menos 1 así que se verá algo así
será como un espejo de iu igual a x
cuadrada pero reflejado sobre el eje
horizontal así que se verá más o menos
así esto es igual a menos x cuadrada
ahora imaginemos que la ajustamos aún
más como se considera la ye igual a
igual a menos 2x cuadrada bueno primero
permítanme hacer dos cosas cómo se vería
llegó a la 2x cuadrada primero hagamos
la versión positiva entonces de igual
datos equis cuadrada ahora aparte de
elevar cada valor al cuadrado lo
multiplicaremos por 2 así que va a
empezar a crecer más rápido se verá como
esto será más angosta y alargada será
más o menos así lo que yo quiero es
darles una idea realmente no dibuje esto
escala pero entonces esto lo hará crecer
dependiendo del factor irá creciendo más
si ahora hacemos igual a menos 2 x
cuadrada igual a menos 2 x cuadrada
entonces se hará negativo más rápido así
que se verá así será un espejo de lo que
acabo de dibujar entonces será una
parábola una parábola más angosta justo
como ésta e igualmente y sé que mi
diagrama se está poniendo bastante
confuso pero solo recuerden que
empezamos con ye igual a x cuadrada que
es esta curva
qué pasaría si hiciéramos de igual a un
medio de x cuadrada este me estoy
quedando sin colores también pero bueno
si hiciéramos llego a la un medio de x
cuadrada entonces las cosas empezarían a
crecer más lento se verá igual pero más
abierta hacia arriba crecerá más
lentamente se verá algo algo así
ojalá que esto les da idea de cómo
podemos ajustar las parábolas si por
ejemplo si por ejemplo tengo tengo voy a
hacerlo voy a hacer un dibujo un poco
burdo aquí para darles la idea general
de lo que estamos hablando entonces si
es igual a x cuadrada ésta es la gráfica
de llego a la x cuadrada esta es igual a
x cuadrada la gráfica de g
voy a usar un color que no haya usado
todavía la gráfica de menos acá igual
por x menos
al cuadrado se verá así
en lugar de que el vértice esté en 0 0
el vértice o lo más bajo o se podría
decir el punto mínimo o máximo el punto
extremo de la parábola este punto de
aquí sería el punto máximo de una
parábola que abre hacia abajo o el punto
mínimo de una que abre hacia arriba ese
punto estará desplazado h hacia la
derecha h hacia la derecha y acá
unidades hacia arriba entonces el
vértice estará por aquí y va a estar
escalado por shia es mayor que si es
igual a 1 se verá igual tendrá la misma
abertura tendrá la misma abertura si a
es igual a 1 si es mayor que 1 será más
angosta algo así pero si a es menor que
1 pero mayor que 0 tendrá una abertura
más ancha como esto ahora si a es
exactamente 0 se convierte en una línea
recta y si a es negativo pero menor que
menos 1
una amplia abertura algo así más bien
debí decir si es mayor que menos 1 si
está entre 0 y menos uno tendrá una
amplia abertura como esta
en uno negativo se verá como un reflejo
de nuestra curva original y por último
si a es menor que menos 1 o sea más
negativo entonces será una parábola más
angosta que se verá como ésta entonces
espero que eso les dé una buena idea de
cómo ajustar y desplazar parábolas